السيده ميناج اليوم نريد ان نفهم اكثر
تفاصيل يعني حول قضيه اللاعب اشرف حكيمي
التي طرات في هذه الايام لماذا يقول
مقربون بان حكيمه تم خداعه وان مساله
الاغتصاب كانت مدبره كيف
للاسف انا لا استطيع ان ارد على ذلك فهو
فهو موضوع تحت السريه القضائيه ليس هناك
اي امكانيه لتسرب اي معلومات من قبل
الامكان من القضاء او من الشرطه لكن هناك
معلومات في الصحافه حول عدد من المعلومات
حول هذه القضيه وما اقوله عبر الصحافه
وعبر المصادر المختلفه هناك المعلومه
الاول وهو ان هناك سيده اتت الى مركز
الشرطه ليس لتقديم شكوى ضد حقيم ولكن
للاعلان عن تعرضها للاغتصاب وعلينا ان
نعرف بانه في القانون
الفرنسي ليس هناك ضروره او اجبار للتقدم
بدعوى ضد شخص ولكن انا اعلان عن الجريمه
اعلان اعلام السلطات امر مهم جدا ان نقول
للسلطات بان شيئا ما خطا حصل وليس هناك
ضروره لتقديم دعوى شخص فاذا هذه السيده
لتعلن عن تعرضها للاغتصاب ولكن ليس لتقديم
دعوه ضد حكيمي ولكن هذا كافن لكي تتحرك
الشرطه والسلطات
والمدعي العام للجمهوريه تقدم وقام
بالتحقيق وكلف قد تحقيق بان يكون هناك
تحقيق
لمواجهه اشرف حكيمي ولمتابعته ملاحقته
ونحن في اطار قضيه جرميه جزائيه وهناك
بحسب القانون مهلك 18 شهرا اعطيت لقاضي
التحقيق للاستماع الى السيد حكيمي ولكن
للسيده المتقدمه بالشكوى او بالاخبار ولكن
ايضا الاستماع
للشهود
للخبراء الخبراء الذين سيقدمون نظرتهم لما
حصل لها جسديا ونفسيا ولكن هناك ايضا بانه
وهذه معلومات متداوله في الشرطه هو انها
اتت الى حكيمي سياره تاكسي او اوبر
وبالتالي يجب الوصول الى هذا السائق وان
نعرف فعلا ماذا حصل في الليله هناك الكثير
من المعطيات التي يجب ان يتم التحقيق بها
وامل بان يتم ان تسمح كل هذه الامور لقد
التحقيق بالوصول الى معطيات واضحه
اذا كان هناك فعلا كما يقول
السيد حكيمي خدعه ام ان هناك جريمه او شيء
ما حصل وماذا كان ذلك الشيء يعاقب بموجب
القانون ام ان اذا كانت هذه العلاقه
هل فعلا الشابه التي وجهتهمه الاغتصاب
لاشرف حكيمي رفضت اجراء اي فحص طبي او
نفسي
ليس هناك بالحقيقه جواب لذلك هذه معلومه
متداوله ولكن السريه القضيه
تغطي هذه المعلومات وانا ليس لدي تاكيد
لهذه المعلومات طيب
نريد ان نفهم ايضا فيما يتعلق بالقانون
الفرنسي كيف يعرف الاغتصاب هل للاغتصاب هو
اخصاب رجل على اقامه علاقه جنسيه مع امراه
ام يمكن تعريف الاقتصاد بمسميات اخرى في
فرنسا يعني فقط لا الامر متعلق بعلاقه
جنسيه مثلا
الفقره القضائيه التي تحدث او القانونيه
التي تحدث تتحدث عن الاغتصاب واضحه
الاغتصاب هو كل عمليه جنسيه كامله
بالاكراه بالعنف بالمفاجاه
وبالتالي هناك مفهوم
التوافق ليس هناك اول القبول وبالتالي ان
الوضع واضح جدا ان
الموافقه من قبل الضحيه على هذه العمليه
يجعل بان هناك هناك اختصار وبالتالي ليس
هناك تركيز على ما قال ما فعلت الضحيه
تركيز
التعريف للاغتصاب يرتكز فقط على ما قام به
المعتدي قد يكون هناك
اغتصاب كامل في اي شكل من الاشكال وهناك
اي نوع من الاغتصاب الجنسي ولكن هناك
انتهاك او هاتك لجسد المراه بشكل حسي باي
شكل من الاشكال
بالمفاجاه بالاكراه
او بالعنف اذا هذه هي العوامل التي تحدد
ان هناك اختصار السؤال الاخير فقط الوضع
القانوني الالي اشرف حكيمي هل هو مخول
بمغادره الاراضي الفرنسيه هو تحت الرقابه
القضائيه ماذا ذلك
ان السيد حكيمي وضع تحت مراقبه قضائيه
وبالتالي ان العداله او القضاء تطلب من
السيد حكيمي بان يعلن عن مكان تواجده
ولكنها حر تماما بالتحرك وبالذهاب الى حيث
يشاء ان القضاء يراقب هناك عدد من
المواضيع او الاجراءات المفروضه على السيد
حكيمي ولكن الاهم هو لا يكون هناك علاقه
او تواجد لحكيمي مع هذه السيده ولكن ليس
هناك قرار من القانون من القاضي التحقيق
بان يغادر او ان يبقى في فرنسا هو حر
بالتحرك بما لا يؤثر على
حياته المهنيه يستطيع السيد حكيمي ان
يتابع حياته المهنيه بشكل كامل عمله
الرياضي وان يغادر او يعود او يعمل ما
يريد
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المداخله من باريس
المحاميه ماريون ميناج